five minutes seek a game game one got my
pen here
got the tea got the water i've got
everything all right
and let's go e4
[Music]
okay so um okay he goes okay so we've
been playing the italian i don't see any
reason to change that uh the italian is
a great opening to okay so h6
is uh is is a very weird move now in
these types of situations we know that
there are two main reactions right we
can open up the center immediately with
d4 or
we can prepare to occupy the center
which is my preferred option
how do we prepare to occupy the center
with pawns and i like to occupy the
center with bonds that's just a personal
bias
there's nothing wrong with the move d4
but i really enjoy the move c3
because i feel like when we occupy the
center with pawns well here we go we
played d4 with tempo we attacked the
bishop
and he's going to be in very big trouble
here he just wasted a move with the move
h6
not something that you can really afford
to do in the italian now as i've talked
about time and time again
one of the key mistakes that players
often make
when they seek to punish a move like h6
is to be overzealous right they will
they will sack on f7 they'll think that
they have to play very actively
the reality is uh the way to punish
these types of moves is to play in a
very measured style
which is not to say you don't want to
attack but you want to do so in a very
sort of
principled manner that is conducive to
also the main principles you want to
keep developing in other words
and what we're going to do here is just
keep developing our pieces we're not
going to do anything crazy and
what i want you guys to observe is that
even though we don't do anything crazy
uh thank you moose man for the prime we
are still going to very effectively
punish
our opponent for wasting a move with a
move h6 in fact he continues to waste
time with bishop a5 so in the spirit of
what i just described
how would we continue the game if we
wanted to play as unimaginatively as
possible
just continue developing our pieces and
making the moves we know we have to make
we're just gonna castle and he can do
whatever the hell he wants he can take
on c3
first we do the basic stuff then and
only then
do we actually go after our opponent now
we basically set the table we protect
our king is safe now we can start to
think about attacking
the weak spots in his position there's
two main approaches here there is a very
advanced move
uh that i would actually play which
bases itself on
some loose pieces but the classic move
here is queen b3
we've seen this one before right
combining with the bishop setting up a
battery
uh and attacking the f7 pawn which he
allows us to take uh he shouldn't have
done that but he was already in very big
trouble we'll talk about that after the
game what would have happened had he
simply defended that pawn with his queen
uh we know already that the queen is a
very bad defender so how
how do we follow this up what do we do
now we've taken this pawn
um and we've taken this pawn
let me just note this down what do we do
now
well um if we move this bishop away some
of you guys are noticing
then we will pave the way for the queen
to come to f7
right the bishop looks very fancy bishop
g6 i like a little bit less because it
would have allowed him to play queen f6
with tempo
attacking the bishop and simultaneously
defending f7 so don't always go for that
most appealing move
uh you know the bishops and queens are
very easily misunderstood pieces
they are just as good from a distance as
they are close by in fact they are often
better from a distance that that is what
makes them
strong okay that was a pretty easy game
he didn't
do anything in particular to stop our
threats we will look at this after
two more games are played in the
meantime let us continue almost to 1300
so we are
you know our level is rising and we're
going to get another italian here
i don't think anybody minds that okay so
d5 that is a very common
opening at the basic level i have even
played this with black
against other gm's who often don't know
how to react to this
uh and i myself don't know exactly what
the best line is
this is called the elephant gambit let's
just take on d5 he's playing it in a
very weird way c6 is not the move
now the first the default in
in any gamut should be the question what
if i just take those pawns what does he
really
gain uh from the gimba and in this
position there are in fact
two pawns that we can take and which
pawn do you think we should take should
we take the c6 pawn
or should we take the e5 pawn i'll give
you in both moves are fine
neither loses but uh one is positionally
noticeably better than the other let's
see yes
uh you guys are correct now if we take
the c6 pawn right we help him develop
we do not want to help our opponent
develop
so we're going to take a central pawn he
takes with the queen we know that taking
with the queen in such positions is very
dangerous because we still have a knight
on b1
that could in the right circumstances
come out to c3
with tempo but first we need to take
care of the knight of e5 do we need to
move it back or can we perhaps
defend it in a manner conducive to our
development we absolutely can and i like
that you guys are thinking in that
precisely that direction
d4 yeah uh we're up upon his queen is
misplaced uh
and he continues to push his pawns and
dig himself deeper into
a hole c5 is not actually as bad of a
move as it may appear
because he's undermining our knight the
way that i would approach this move is
to ask ourselves
what the drawback of the move c5 is does
it perhaps weaken any diagonals
i know that you guys are thinking bishop
c4 but be very careful because he can
take on g2 with the queen and we know
that that particular move can lead to
very nasty consequences so
if we think about where to develop this
bishop let's develop it to b5 and by
asking ourselves what the drawback of
the move c5
is we can understand that it also
weakens this diagonal allows our bishop
to
go out there now now what we're going to
do is called
transforming the advantage we are up
upon
yes and we're up upon everybody is on
board with that
but but in order to actually win this
game we're going to have to do
is make a strategic counter sacrifice
what we're going to do
knight c3 he still takes the pawn on g2
guys we need to solve the problem of the
spot on trees if we are going to
counter sacrifice the pawn on d4 in
return
for very rapid development which means
what what can what i mean what simple
move can we make here just
ignoring the fact that d4 pawn is
hanging this is a very powerful
very powerful concept uh that may not
seem
that fancy it may not seem that
impressive to anybody watching though
why is daniel going crazy about some
bullcrap
uh and just bear with me because after
the game i will explain
what makes this concept of transforming
the advantage so powerful
how do we react to this situation our
night is actually
not hanging i'm gonna give people a hint
the night is not hanging why because if
he takes it with a queen
we go rookie one and we pin his queen to
his knight so we have a
very cunning move here we can attack his
queen
because the knight is essentially
untouchable now how should we attack the
queen
i know everybody wants to play rookie
one but that's actually not the best
move
remember if he takes on e5 with his
queen then and
only then do we play rookie one let us
play bishop c4 this is a very advanced
five head move
we are essentially compelling him to
take our knight if he doesn't take our
knight
then we're going to play knight takes f7
and we're going to win his rook so he
either loses his rook or he loses his
queen lb
it for a rook and a piece but because
this king is stuck in the center that
queen is going to be worth
so much more than the rook end piece so
we're going to be essentially winning
the rest is going to be a matter of
bringing the rest of our pieces up and
exploiting that open e file
hopefully i've explained the process of
finding this move
which takes its origin in breaking down
your assumptions about the position and
the times rejecting your assumptions
the better you are at chess uh the less
assumptions
you tend to make about the position and
the more you tend to question your
fundamental beliefs right
so most people will look at this
position and say okay my knight on e5 is
hanging i have to solve that so let me
take his knight
but what i encourage people to do is is
immediately question that assumption
right
is my knight actually hanging what
happens if he takes it well
then what you see is that you have the
move rookie one so you can use that as a
huge bargaining chip right you can
essentially use the fact
that the knight isn't really hanging
he's gone bishop c5 he is completely
crumbling
what simple move do we have here to
finish the game
that is a very typical mistake he
assumes that the bishop is defended of
course the bishop is not defended
because
the knight is pinned so we can simply
take this bishop he cannot take our
queen because the king
the knight is pinned to the king right
pins are
you know the language of tactics uh
and and and they have to be mastered
right every single pit particularly one
against the king
must be noticed paid attention to and
incorporated in your thought process
one more game and then we will analyze
and this game will hopefully help us
reach 1200
if we win indeed if we win we will reach
exactly 1200. now
our opponent plays d4 and we have been
responding so far with the queen's
gambit which i believe
is the right of passage of most players
most of you guys should be playing the
queen's cabin
um when you're beginners now there are
some exceptions king's indian is
actually a good opening was for some
beginners
uh but not for everybody okay that would
be scary if somebody were entering my
door
uh now in the queen's gamut the the
purpose is
very simple there are two main ideas of
playing the queen's game
the first is we establish a you know a
very
uh well serious claim in the center we
establish pawn on d5 that pawn on d5 is
defended by the pawn on e6 the second
thing we do is we
aim to quickly and sort of effectively
develop our king side
without entirely sacrificing the
activity of our pieces right our knight
is nicely developed to f6 now the bishop
one could say is a little bit passive
but the reality is this bishop on e7
look at it very carefully
it can actually be the instrument that
allows us to increase
our claim over the center and that's
exactly what we're going to do here this
bishop could support
another pawn push that could create
tension in the center which is
very complex right it doesn't
necessarily favor either side
and that's what makes d4 openings
oftentimes different from e4 openings
you get this sort of positional battle
neither one of our kings
is in particular danger of getting
checkmated where the tension is
occurring is in the center
it's all about the pawns here uh and
it's a lot more positional than in
let's say a king's gambit right where
things get crazy very very fast
and it's all about who checkmates who
okay so he plays a good move bishop g5
depends on
our knight and what does it mean in this
case to pin our knight what this means
is that the pawn on d5 loses a very
important defender
potentially so what we need to do is we
need to add
a defender to the d5 pawn right so that
we counteract the effect
of this nasty move bishop g5 what does
that mean we have to play bishop
but this movie is really powerful daniel
well guess what we're black
we're playing against a d4 opening
sometimes we need to bite the bullet
and play a couple of passive moves and
this move isn't so much passive as it is
a defensive move
uh defensive moves aren't necessarily
bad and here we go we're already reaping
the benefits of it he stubbornly takes
on f6
but because this bishop is nicely
protecting the d5 phone what does that
mean
that means he cannot take the pawn with
the queen he can only take it with the
knight
he does take it with the knight and that
is ladies and gentlemen a mistake
because he doesn't stop to consider the
ramifications of this move
what are the drawbacks of this move and
i would like you guys to answer that
question what are the drawbacks of that
move
well we can first of all take on d5 and
take on b2 there's no actual need to
take the knight on t5 we can take on b2
immediately
the rook da be careful he's he's
attacking our queen
with check right and even if it wasn't
checked we would not want to go rook d a
now this move is one to break down so
let me just write this down
um 11 queen takes b2
discuss now he plays knight for that is
a blunder
now i have said time and time again that
the queen is the worst defender of
pieces and pods
we see here that the queen on d1 defends
the rook on a1 so we must find a way now
to get that queen
out of the d1 square we do so by going
to should before check
it is essentially checkmate were it not
for the move knight d2 but after 92
uh your intuition should indicate that
he is on the verge of collapse
we simply take on d2 if he takes with
the queen we take the rook if he doesn't
then
checkmate him so he must choose between
a rock and a hard place
here we go we win the rook and we win
the game right how did i find this
well as i said the first thing i noticed
was the fact that
white's queen defends the rock on a1 and
there are no other pieces that defend
that rook so if we can
get that queen out of d1 force it onto
another square
that rook on a1 is going to be hanging
and we use our other active pieces
to do that right you look at your other
active pieces we're just going to take
the queen and take the pawn we're going
to win this in a very simple way
as i've said many times when you decide
to go for method
one of converting a material advantage
uh and those of you who've seen the
speedo should know what method one means
which is essentially trading
as many pieces as possible and winning
the resulting end game
one additional crucial component of
doing that method involves creating past
pawns pass bonds
are perhaps the single most important
factor of any endgame
and when we create them and when we're
up material our opponent simply does not
have the firepower
available to stop them from eventually
promoting and either making new queens
or
forcing our opponent to give up more
pieces uh to take those
newly promoted queens so we're simply
going to push that a pawn we're not
going to do anything which is pushing
that a pawn
that apon simultaneously defends the
bishop which is always a nice byproduct
of past pawns
and we're going to keep pushing it did i
blunder the bishop on v3 he's almost
definitely going to take it in about two
seconds
did we blunder this bishop on b3 well
he's realized
that something is amiss i still think
he's going to take it but we'll see
um obviously we have not because we go
e2 and the pawn is unstoppable such is
the power
of past pawns now you might be wondering
right now why are past pawns important
in the end game are they important also
in the middle game well yes you know
can you promote a passport in the middle
game you absolutely can right it's
possible
it's possible to promote a passport in
the middle game um
if your opponent is neglectful but when
you've got a lot of pieces on the back
rank when you have a queen and you have
two rooks
the probability of promoting a passpond
in the middle game
is going to be just pretty low right
it's it's not going to be easy but in
the end game you have
very few resources left uh consider it
in a sense a situation in soccer right
where the goalkeeper comes out to kick
the final corner kick
the end game is like that final corner
kick where the goalie has come out of
the gate
and there's nobody guarding the goal
right the goal being the first rank here
and so it's very very easy to get this
rook out of a1
and he resigns okay and we're exactly at
1200.
so let's quickly go over these were
relatively simple games but nonetheless
let's go over them
and as we are going over the game
perfect
timing we have a raid by grand master
gary my good friend awesome player and
awesome person
thank you so much gary hope you had a
fantastic stream
uh and uh welcome everybody you came at
a great time because
this is daniel i am doing my
instructional speed run uh not for very
much
longer but uh we have just finished the
first set of three games and i'm about
to analyze them
so i hope you guys stick around thank
you so much gary and have a great rest i
hope you had a great stream
okay so in this first game that i played
today in the speed run
there was an italian he wasted time with
h6 and we played c3
the purpose of this move is to occupy
the center with the pawns specifically
and whether or not you play d4 and try
to occupy it with pieces is a matter of
taste
i simply like the move c3 okay so d4
takes takes bishop b6 knight c3
developing very simply
uh and after bishop a5 castle c6 this
was one of the
important moments now the move that i uh
was
sort of referencing as a potentially
advanced move
is actually d5 now you might be looking
at this and saying
whoa whoa whoa whoa you are voluntarily
blocking
your own bishop that seems to be
precisely the piece that's
giving the advantage what am i doing
well the reason i'm thinking about the
move d5 and actually i don't think it's
as good of a move as i initially thought
what justifies the move d5 what was my
follow-up intention
what do what does white do in this
position and can somebody for extra
credit
thank you gary for the 11 months why is
this move that i thought was good
queen a4 check not as good as i
initially thought
black sc6 and this is what you have to
be really careful about now the queen
defense a5
now we could reopen the bishop on c4
right by taking on c6 we could do that
uh but what what will we have gained
from this transformation
this is where things get very five head
look at this knight on e7 ladies and
gentlemen
look at it very very carefully what is
the
function of what is this knight doing
what this knight is doing is it's
blocking the queen on d8
why is it important that the knight is
blocking the queen well we have an idea
that we can reapply here
which is particularly effective now
because the queen from d8
can no longer come to the support of
this particular thing
now what am i talking about what can
white do now and this
involves combining ideas knight t5 is
actually a very good move
using this pin but think back to what i
actually ended up doing in the game
knight g5 doesn't work the opponent is a
knight
but de la citis you have the right idea
you're looking at the spawn on f7 and
you want to attack it
let's attack that pawn on f7 guys
remember
we played this move in the game and it's
okay to make a retreating move
i think this is a big problem for a lot
of players is they're unwilling to
consider retreating moves bingo
and this is the magic of what we just
did the knight from e7 is disallowing
the queen from coming to the pond's
rescue and without that
black simply has no way of defending the
pawn without
making the incredibly nasty and uh
well the move f6 really doesn't even
need discussion i mean black's position
is riddled with holes
so what we've done here is we've
essentially provoked a
weakening then we reopen the diagonal
and we slide the queen back to f3
now the reason this is important is
because in the game i played queen b3
immediately
and our opponent could have gone queen
e7 and defended the pawn with this queen
as it turns out
the move queen e7 is perhaps less
effective than it appears
could somebody tell me why the reason is
very very straightforward what does
white have at his disposal
which is precisely the reason that black
should have
well which is precisely the reason that
they can push upon for 200 bits
95 is exactly right attacking the queen
get out of here
what do we do in a position like this
well we can do a bunch of different
things we can continue opening up the
center
uh we won't delve too deeply into this
but it's uh well i'm glad to hear that
pushy fun
so uh but but in any case at any rate
night
you know inducing 97 would have taken
this out of the equation
as it stands our opponent took it out of
the equation by simply giving that pawn
up
and now we drop the bishop back to h5
paving the way for queen f7 again
if he goes queen f6 we can go 95 chasing
his queen away
and if you go screen d a what should we
do in this position how should we
actually
finish this game off uh in the most
efficient
manner
yeah we should simply play knight takes
bishop and help ourselves to
a all-you-can-eat buffet consisting of
black's entire queenside
uh so that would be the simplest way of
playing
on to game two uh but are there any
questions about
this game and again i wanna make it very
very clear and i'm not just saying
this right i want to make everybody feel
comfortable no matter whether your
ratings a hundred a thousand or
two thousand or three thousand um and we
do have some three thousands here
occasionally
so uh if there is a question that you're
on the fence about asking
you're maybe a little bit embarrassed uh
this is a place where we're all here to
learn i make mistakes all the time
uh i'm open about that and so should you
uh
you know the likelihood is
everybody wanted to ask that question
and was just afraid so please
by all means you know whatever you want
to ask just
fire away as long as it's on topic okay
is d5 b4 achieve anything yeah knight b4
is the right idea but it doesn't
actually attack the c6 knight
because the c6 knight is defending you
want to be careful about these kinds of
moves right
if you wanted to move the knights
somewhere else except b6 you could play
well you could not play knight take c7
this falls into something i shared
before which is that when you're
discovering something you want to make
sure that your opponent cannot take
the piece that is doing the discovering
and simultaneously
defend the piece or the square that is
being discovered
so you could also go knight f4 that is a
very subtle move but it essentially
threatens knight g6 this would also be
immediately winning
because knight g6 is devastating and so
is queen f7
black doesn't have defense against both
of these at the same time
okay great looks like everybody's clear
this next game was very straightforward
as well
he played the elephant game we take e5
um because why is pushing middle pawns
not good here
um yeah well because we were sort of
playing with our pieces
um at what point is it actually worth it
to learn things for openings besides
opening principles well
i do not subscribe and i normally don't
answer these general questions but but
because we talked a lot about the
opening here
let me add my two cents ladies and
gentlemen all this briefly
briefly and i will expand on this later
i do not subscribe
to the uh preeminent and sort of
prevailing i should say
coaching philosophy in many ways right
and my students know this i have very
unconventional coaching methods and
views on chess
and one of the ways in which this
manifests itself is i don't i don't
believe
in this whole thing that that beginners
should not learn openings i absolutely
think beginners should learn openings
and i think they should learn them
deeply
i you know probably went you know
maybe a thousand and above right when
you hit 900 or a thousand that's when
you should really start learning
openings
but there's a lot of coaches who say you
shouldn't touch openings until you're
like 1800 or
i've even heard some people say until
you're 2000 uh
bs complete bs that will hold you back
tremendously and learning openings at an
early stage
actually helps you not only acquire
results
uh which i last i checked people want to
win games
and what's wrong with that but the
second thing is it actually helps you
cement general chess principles when you
know your opening as well you get good
positions
when you get good positions you have a
greater chance at
fostering the right kinds of habits
early so actually i would say that you
should start learning openings at a
relatively deep level
when you hit a thousand you should try
to build up an opening repertoire
that is at an approximately 15 1600
level which means that you shouldn't
learn theory to move 25
do not take this too far right i'm not
saying you should
you know find magnus carlsen's email and
hire him for a an opening training camp
for a week
and have him teach you his files right
there's
a middle ground here but you should
definitely have a reference war you
should
you should memorize some of the main
lines and you should understand them uh
and that's my two cents i'm happy to
expand on this but i will do that later
um okay so in this game we take the pawn
on e5 in order not to help him develop
his pieces
which would have been the case here uh
now we play d4 to
cement the knight and i was as i was
going to say right bishop c4
you want to be incredibly careful when
you make a move like bishop c4 when the
queen is in the center in general and
this is a
specific piece of advice for people uh
when your opponent's queen is in the
center that is both a good thing for you
and a bad thing right well bathing like
it's a thing to be careful about
because the queen in the center has
access to all sides of the board
and so you should be especially careful
when you're developing your pieces that
you're not leaving any pawns hanging
particularly the g2 pod right that's
something you can literally check for
in these types of situations uh so what
we did here is we developed with tempo
and we just castled we gave
up the pawn back in order to transform
our advantage from a material advantage
to pat the pawn into an initiative right
a development advantage
and an attack and chess games often
cannot be won
without understanding the moments when
you take one type of
advantage such as an initiative and
transform it into another such as a
material advantage
or as we did here vice versa and this
move bishop c4 was at the crux of our
play now rookie one would have been very
good as well setting up a discovered
check which could have been devastating
but bishop c4 is even stronger because
we basically
forcibly win his queen and then we win
another pawn and then a bishop
okay so that was straightforward which
brings us to
this final game uh the queen's gambit
and as i explained this is a more
positional opening we get a very common
structure here
what is the structure generally called
can somebody supply for maybe
term that is often used well it's it's a
self-explanatory term how are these
structures called
iqp iqp stands for isolated queen spawn
isolated means there is no neighboring
pawns
queen's pawn well it is a green pawn
isolated queen spawns because it can
occur
uh for white and for black an example of
an opening in which
white is the one who possesses an
isolated queen pawn is the pawn of
karo khan to give you an approximation
this would be a position in which white
has an isolated queen spawn
uh or an iqb so this happens you know
from both sides
now one moment please okay now
um this time i was the one with an iqp
you cannot say in one breath whether
isolated queen spots
are good or bad that depends almost
entirely on the way that the pieces are
placed
why is that the case
there are many situations in which
isolated queen spawns
are extremely problematic and in fact
the general principle by which you can
understand
uh isolated queen pond positions is is
and this is very general there's
exceptions
the less pieces there are on the board
the more
the isolated queen's pawn becomes less
of a strength and more of a weakness
so if you imagine a graph right the the
the less pieces there's an inverse
inversely proportional relationship
between the strength of the
of the isolated queen's pawn and the
number of pieces on the board right
i'm not i feel like i'm over
complicating this but you get the point
the less pieces there are the weaker
that isolated queen's bond is now why is
that the case
the reasoning is very simple right
there's just not enough pieces left to
defend it
um it just becomes like any other
backward or weak bond when there's
almost no pieces left it has to be
defended by all of your pieces
and that's never a good thing to have
something you have to tie yourself down
to
uh and quad to yesterday thank you for
the twitch prime
i can show you a litany of
model games on the topic of isolated
queens pawns becoming
weak with less pieces on the board um
let me try to see if i can quickly hunt
down one of these
examples i have a game in mind between
karpov and kirchner
and it's only karpov was one of the
greatest specialists in
uh both sides of the isolated queens
bond both with
with the queen pawn and against it uh
and i found
this example so let me go into the
chess-based scene
so this is a game between two players
who i'm sure most of the viewers are
familiar with porch noise and karpov
court schneider of course
one of the strongest grandmasters never
to become world champion
uh and this game was played
in the world championship match 1981 and
they played several of them
between karbov and korchnoy which of
course karpov won
now karbov is playing black here this
was indeed a queen's game and now i
wasn't lying when i told you the queen's
gambit leads to a lot of isolated queen
spot positions for both sides
here white is the one with the isolated
queen
pawn now i want you guys to pay very
careful attention to what karpov does in
the next couple of moves
he starts embarking on a campaign
to trade as many pieces as possible
that's all he does right he doesn't do
anything mysterious
boom knight h5 get those bishops off the
board
and now korchner makes a very
instructive mistake
korchnoy goes 94. now this is 1981 they
didn't necessarily understand
structures as well as we do now there
are certain things that we take for
granted
which players of the time you know
sometimes stumble
korchnoy helps karpov trade all of the
pieces boom boom
boom and now look what happens
well all of the minor pieces almost all
of the minor pieces are gone
and with the minor pieces gone this
d-pawn has just become a regular
weakness
white has no more pieces left to attack
with and so karpov just starts to attack
this bomb look at this
all of white's pieces every single one
of them other than the bishop are tied
down
to the protection of this d4 pawn and
that is a disaster and course joy makes
things even worse
he trades the last pair of minor pieces
this is an
incredibly famous textbook example of
how to play against the iqp
black has traded all of the minor pieces
and literally now all of white's
remaining pieces are saddled
toward the protection of the spawn which
karpov dooley
wins well he doesn't actually win it but
he uses it as a ploy
and he opens up the position of white's
king and because white is so tied down
to the pawn
white neglects the safety of his king
and gets checkmated
and he loses his rook and he loses his
queen so uh i really went fast through
this game
but i hope that it at least partially
illustrates how to play against the
isolated principle now how do you play
with the isolated queen pawn
well obviously by newton's
law of opposite reactions you need to
keep as many pieces on the board as
possible
and one of the classical ways of playing
with the iqp is actually to prepare its
advance forward
one of the scariest scenarios when you
have the iqp is allowing a pawn push
such as d4 which not only rids you of
that iqb
but oftentimes leads to disastrous
consequences for the side that allows
the prawn break
okay so often times the battle when you
talk about
uh is occurring on the square in front
of it
is the side that's playing against the
iqb going to be able to establish a
blockade
on that square or is the side that has
the iqp
going to be able to push that iqp
forward uh
absolve themselves of the iqp and as a
consequence
uh develop a tremendous initiative so
that is often
the battle now i'm really
oversimplifying this there's a lot of
of of intricacies there have been books
written about the iqb
literally and i can direct you to some
but i think this is more than enough for
the average
player i hope that this at least
partially clarifies things i know it's a
bit of a mysterious topic iqb
uh but hopefully you know people are at
least a little bit more in the clear
about
what can happen uh in iqp type positions
uh now what we did in the game was we
actually lent some support to the iqp
our opponent attempted to take that iqp
immediately
and this leads me to the second point
about iqp's which is that they're often
mind mind pawns right they're often like
land mines you step on them
they explode and unintended consequences
arise as a result because white is not
developed as king side
he's just not ready to to meet this
right he's not ready for the queen to
appear on b2
and he loses very very quickly um i
could have also taken the knight first
and then gun queen takes b2
but i wanted to keep the tension right
this knight on d5 is not dangerous
if it comes to c7 i go bishop before
check
and once again i just take on d2 just
just like i did in the game
okay uh the rest was very simple we take
the rook betray the queens and win
the rest of um
take the rest of white spawns um absolve
luis lucha
okay absolve that's a good word okay any
questions about this game or any
questions about my explanation of the
iqp
before i move on to the next set of
games
how do you play against complex
aggressive gambits or traps like
elephant without knowing anything about
a theater well
this brings me first and foremost back
to my point which is that you want to
learn the theory of these gametes
that is what i'm working on right now
i'm working on a project where i analyze
all of these gambits that's a hard
project that
danish the england the stafford and you
know the elephant
even if you're a beginner you want to
learn at least a couple of moves in each
of these
gambits so that you don't have to think
independently every time you're faced
with them
but fundamentally when you're faced with
a gamba that you feel like might be
annoying
you feel like might be might be
dangerous uh you want to first and
foremost
adhere to general principles right if
you're developing your pieces
if you're not grabbing questionable
pawns then chances are nothing terrible
is going to happen to you if you are not
sure about taking a pawn that is gamuted
to you
by some opponent then don't take it
simply keep developing and a great
example of that
uh i faced this move that i actually
wasn't even familiar with
the move knight d4 in the italian i
wasn't sure about taking the pawn
it turns out that after queen g5 white
is in trouble and so i simply decided to
develop
and as a consequence it turns out that
castles is indeed white's best smoke and
white is something better
okay so you want to weigh the pros and
cons of that that's a very
short cutting kind of thing and it's it
all depends on the specific opening
but that would be a couple of specific
tips on
on that topic